Camila Cabello is getting ready to
launch album number two which is on the
cover of Elle magazine's women and music
issue which would be on newsstands on
September 24th she just dropped two new
songs yesterday that we talked about on
the show
yeah but Elle magazine got her to try
her hand at singing some Celine Bieber
and Mariah in the game song Association
Camilla is given a word and she has to
sing a song with that word in it deeper
than out they have a dream girl inside
when she hits Vic crazy whistle now that
I can't do when I do have a voice but
I'm especially not gonna do it my voice
is shot heart you're here there's
nothing I fear and I know the heart will
go off baby and I was like baby baby
baby oh baby baby baby oh like baby baby
baby who thought you'd always be mine my
word um I'm like a bird on a fly away I
don't know where my soul is I don't know
why mommy I'm like a bird right now at
each other so they said she did okay I
thought that was really good that was
oppressed by krill in that especially
off the cuff like that okay her she
needs to fire whoever allowed that to
happen here's the thing
Camila can sing right those are some of
the greatest singers that she was
singing you know at variety as a singer
obviously I'm speaking for myself
you just have to before you perform
there are a lot of things that go into
it there's a lot of things like
temperature you know certain things that
you can't eat if you have a cold if you
flew a lot of people don't realize like
if you have a cold or even symptoms of a
cold you can't sing if
voices shot don't sing surprise reports
no one could have even allowed her to do
that because now she's just opened
herself up to criticism that I think is
so unfair I don't think that performance
was a true representation of her ability
it's just kind of riffing like I don't
think she's really but you can't it is
not kind of riffing when you're an
athlete you're not just playing around
when you play a game know every time you
sing you have to come with it it's not
we're not at your rehearsal watching you
play around you're singing to the camera
for people and you got to come correct
this is like she's in a big moment in
her career realize that too like it's
not like yeah you don't just sometimes
you just can't you can't just do it off
the cuff and even if you want to do it
off the cuff I think that if you're if
you're saying your voice is shot
you shouldn't have to say yeah but can I
say she's pretty awesome
RZ says this girl's a bland singer damn
I wish when people could actually sing I
think Camila can sing it just sounds
great I think she can sing I don't think
that was a true representation of whisky
as a performer as an athlete as a singer
or whatever you do in an artistic format
you have to bring it a hundred percent
of the time and you have a team that
makes sure it's facilitated so you can
do your job this is impressive I think
she has a beautiful voice sick or not
TSS Mariah Carey has always praised hot
water and honey to help her voice yeah
it's not a concert it's a popular skin
on YouTube she did good I love your
comments the guys
[Music]